i think you'll have all had the agenda
in papers
um prior to today so if we can just
start with
um agenda item one which is attendances
if people would like to introduce
themselves because obviously it's a bit
um you know hopefully the public will be
able to see who's who so
i'll go around my um
screen so and i'm councillor jane slater
i'm the executive member
of health wellbeing and the qualities
here in trafford and i will be chairing
the board today
and heather do you want to introduce
yourself
yeah i'm heather fairfield and i'm the
chair of healthwatch trafford
[Music]
you muted and i didn't do it
sorry about that one i just i was muted
uh
john holden council of st mary's ward in
sale
council uh yes i'm council under
blackburn i'm shadow executive member
for health wellbeing and equalities
noble yeah good morning maureen noble
independent chair of trafford strategic
safeguarding partnership adults and
children
thank you diane
good morning uh diane eaton corporate
director for adults traffic council
martin
martin pritchard accountable officer nhs
trafford
tom
good morning everybody uh tomorrow new
programming metropolis health and care
for the cow and the ccg louise
my name louise wright sport and physical
activity relationship manager
dorothy dorothy evans ceo of african
caribbean care group
and the vcsc representative oh
my screen's changed eleanor
eleanor wrote director on the roster oh
god
come on eleanor roof director of public
health trafford
john
john wearing great strategy at mf team
here for monday bailey
hi rebecca horton i work for trafford
housing trust as a mental health lead
analyst at the traffic council sorry um
my
connection was a bit bad
hello everyone i've had trouble getting
in but i'm here now i'm sally johnson
i'm chair of the cc traffic ccg
councillor brophy
[Music]
we also have councillors
again so um we have council jane brophy
also on the meeting
and somebody on galaxy s9 i'm not sure
who that is
here to support the meeting from
trafford thank you
um i do have some apologies so if these
can be recorded please for the record
uh we have apologies from uh councillor
amnesty
uh mark jarvis michelle hill jill
mcgregor
sean donilon mandy bailey
and jill heaton so um
if we can just record those apologies
please and can we move on to
item two which is the minutes of the
last meeting held on the 14th of august
can those be agreed
as a true reflection please
yes i got a thumbs up from sally so
if they agree um any declarations of
interest from
members
no declarations of interest to record
and i haven't been notified of any
urgent business
and item five i've had no questions from
the public
so if we can please move on to item six
which is the kovid 19 outbreak plan and
that's
over to eleanor okay thank you very much
um so you've got the uh we've sent
across
a copy of the plan so everybody should
be able to see it
um just to give a quick update on the
figures because
as you know it's moving quite fast and
sadly in the wrong direction at the
moment in trafford
so between the 4th and 10th of october
we had 841 new confirmed cases in
trafford
um which gives us a rate of uh just over
350 per hundred thousand population
of those rates um our highest rates are
in our young
people aged 17 to 21 with a particular
peak in um 18 and 19 year olds
we've done a lot more testing so we are
getting much better access to testing
in trafford we've um on average in that
time we were carrying out 417
tests a day 100 000 people
so that's um for trafford that will be
around about uh you know over 800 tests
a day of people
12 12 and a half percent of those are
coming back positive
so that's a high positivity rate we are
fine you know that a lot of people we
are finding
a lot of those um tests of positive
in a lot of positive people and most of
the people when they go for testing
say that they have symptoms um
all of our rates are much higher than
the england average
um i think the most worrying asset well
the good news on this
is that we're seeing the lowest rates
are in our children
um so school age population we're seeing
relative
relatively low rates um
but the most worrying aspect is that we
are seeing increasing rates in our over
60 population
and that at the moment is running at 237
per 100 000 for that time period
that's the population where we're most
concerned that if um
if people get covered that they will be
seriously ill
so the second high apart from those 18
and 19 year olds we're also
starting to see slightly higher rates in
our 45 to 64 population
than our 30 to 44 population and again
that group is the group who are likely
to have contact if you like it they're
that middle
group between maybe older parents and
their own children
so spread in that group is particularly
worrying
because of that that likelihood that it
will spread into
into older populations um
as i say that although we've had a lot
of cases
linked to schools we think almost all in
almost all cases
these are cases that are community
acquired and they're being picked up
because the schools are being really
assiduous
in them in making sure that anyone's
symptomatic is sent home
and is tested um we've seen cases as i
say linked to both staff and
pupils but we're not seeing a lot of
transmission within the schools at the
moment
and the other place where at the moment
um
and we very much hope this will continue
we have had some outbreaks in care homes
but we are not we
you know does feel like at the moment
some of the protective measures that
we've done to protect our care home
residents are working
however as we see that spread into that
older population and
if we keep at the levels we are with our
general population
it will be impossible to safeguard and
protect
the most vulnerable people in our
society so we all
i think the main message i have and the
the aim of
both um i think probably in a way
dealing with this item and the public
engagement board in one
is helpful um is that we are really
needing to get those messages through to
people
about the importance of that
self-isolation the importance
of if you have symptoms please have a
test do not go back to work do not do
anything else other than stay at home
while you're waiting for the results of
that test
and your family should also stay at home
while you're waiting for those results
if you get a positive result you must
self-isolate
and that means staying in your home or
garden if you have a positive result for
the 10 days your household stays there
too
for 14 days
and in order to reduce your risk because
with this level of community
transmission
and antivirus is a virus it's invisible
and it just loves people
and it loves people that love people and
it loves indoors and it loves
poorly ventilated spaces so at the
moment
you know please do go out get exercise
but try and make sure you're outside as
much as you can
if you you know meet friends and family
in a park remember the rule of six
but try not to go you know crowded noisy
indoor spaces
with poor ventilation are going to be
risky um
so really just do do remember that any
of us can catch it
any of us could give it to somebody else
so we do need to try and make sure that
we're all
behaving differently over this next
little while
um and i think that will be through the
winter it's going to be a difficult
winter
um so within the what we've been doing
as a public health team we've divided
our work into several sections we have
um
and in the report you'll have seen the
work we've been doing on testing where
as i said we've increased our
local testing offers and we are getting
good uptake of the testing
we have our local contact racing is now
in place supplementing the national
program
um we'd strongly recommend anybody who
is run by the national program please
please do engage with that national
programme
and do give them the information that
they ask for um
we we follow up with cases that they
that they struggle to get hold of but
with a number of cases that we're
getting through it's over 100 a day
um being testing positive at the moment
so the more that people work with the
national system
the easier it is for us to actually
manage the workload that then comes down
to us
um so that we have um
local contact tracing in place we've
been working strongly with our care
homes and our schools in particular but
also with businesses to try and make
sure that we're
we're reducing the risk in every setting
and with the hospitality industry and i
have to say you know we're getting
really good engagement with most of
those
premises um but quite often you know we
are seeing some outbreaks and we do need
to make sure that that learning is
cascaded and everybody takes this
seriously
we are now really trying to build up the
community engagement element of our work
because this is something that we're not
going to be able to manage this by
enforcement alone and we have to get to
a point where people are engaging with
it
we need to hear from the public about
which are the things that are really
hard for them
which are the things that they they
would like support with in order to
manage the self-isolation and manage
those behavior changes
because i think we're all very aware of
course of the huge mental health impact
the social isolation the fear of using
health services
so i would again stress to people it's
really important at the moment if you
have any illness
contact your gp contact nhs111
make sure that you access certain health
services our health services
are safe and they want to see you but
at the same time do whatever you can to
protect yourself
by by taking those steps particularly
around that social distancing as i was
saying
so um at the moment we're now trying to
really ramp up that um community
engagement work and making sure that
those messages get to everybody in the
community because i think through the
summer
you know when when it was mainly in the
younger population people were thinking
well nobody's in hospital yet but
actually people are now going into
hospital
and the treatment is better we have got
more options the outcomes should be
better
but our hospitals always struggle in
winter
so add this make that you know to it
it's going to be difficult and the other
thing i would say of course is do
remember to have your flu jab
because that will take pressure off the
system as well
so i think if anyone wants any questions
now on that i have to take any questions
uh council blackburn has raised a hand
so and would you like to come in
yes thank you um if a child
has a positive test then the class
bubble or the air bubble
um are you know sent home but
siblings can still go to school from
that bubble could you could you comment
on that
so what we're doing is so in primary
schools
and reception and early years settings
if one child tests positive then the
whole bubble gets
or a teacher test positive in that
bubble then the whole
bubble gets sent home to self-isolate
because it's really hard with that age
group
to know what what they've been up to and
and to manage any social distancing
and to be fair we don't really want
little children to be trying to think
about social distancing it's just not
that's not possible
um so in the primary schools that's what
we do in secondary schools we would
um we would uh
just um usually depending but normally
it's just the close contacts of the of
the staff member or
of the child or young person the reason
that
so what we do is always one degree of
separation
so if a child tests positive
that child and all its household members
will self-isolate all the people in the
bubble will self-isolate
but the siblings of the children in the
bubble won't self-isolate because they
haven't had direct contact with the case
does that make sense
so you that's why we don't take it one
step
further okay
and just secondly
sorry and i've just um we've had
notification that there's going to be
the new testing center
at soccerdome just near to the trafford
center
that's that's um you know is that going
to be
um you know is that going to be
communicated
widely and i've also asked whether or
not there's going to be um
a sign put up you know street furniture
to indicate
that there is a testing center nearby
and
so that people can be directed to it yes
we'll be doing all that when it goes
when it goes live we'll be doing all the
communication uh in that area and
and more widely to make sure that
everybody knows it's there we'll also be
doing further communication to remind
people when they get a test
that they must self-isolate until they
get the results because we really
we have seen some cases where people
haven't haven't remembered that they
needed to do that
or weren't aware i think quite quite
honestly i think sometimes people aren't
aware
so we're going to be making sure that we
get good publicity and uh
good signage for for all of our sites
absolutely
thank you elena and does anybody else
have any further questions
jane it's me coming in sally i haven't
got a hand to put up i'm afraid so i've
just burst in
um it's just it's not a question it's
just to make the point
that the amount of non-copied harm that
is being done
to society is absolutely immense
my day is spent speaking to people with
exacerbation of mental health problems
new presentation of mental health
problems where people didn't have them
before
um people are all worn out worried
and sad and um i sometimes think
that the there seems i know covert has
to take priority
i just want to raise raise the fact that
a lot of people are coming to harm
because of the restrictions put up on
their live lives by covered we have
people scared to come to the doctor
so we know people are presenting late i
don't know what can be done about it
i just want people to be aware of it is
really really bad
i think it's absolutely i'm sorry
it's very honest i'm going to say i
think with some of our comments that you
know we are trying to get that point
over now aren't we that actually
it's safe to go to the doctors if you
you know for an appointment because the
you know the surgeries will be covered
safe and obviously we're going to have
um
covered safe hospitals going forward so
you know we just need to be making sure
that when we're speaking to people that
we make you know
if you have got symptoms of whatever it
is you need to speak up and get help so
it's
whether that is around mental health or
physical health we need
everybody to be engaging and we will you
know
we know that there is capacity to help
those people so
um yes covert is a priority for us
because of what it can do and how it can
rip through our society but you know we
i think we are aware so sorry ellen i
think you were going to come back with
something else weren't you
well i was just all of that but also i
think we need to be trying to get some
more positive messaging out
to people about what they can do safely
and how they can do that safely and one
of those things is absolutely you should
be seeing your friends and family
but just think about where you are
maintain that social distancing you know
we can't go into people's houses
but we can go for walks together and we
should be doing that we should be
maintaining those social contacts so
it's what we can do safely and how we do
it safely
rather and i i am really as you say i'm
very concerned about
you know we we are seeing excess deaths
from other causes
and it is exacerbating inequalities in
our society
so it is something that we need to be
getting some some positive messaging
out as well as you know just trying to
frighten people is not helpful
thank you diane did you want to come in
it was really to follow on i suppose the
the response around the winter plan
chair
when you want me to cover that
please diane if you can so i think the
members of the board have had a
presentation
which will and i won't go through every
slide because it's quite long but i'm
just going to pull out some key points
for you on the on the approach to the
winter plan
and the plan has been uh is much bigger
than it normally is we do a winter plan
every year but this year we have got
really um extensive requirements both
from the
nhs requirements and adult social care
so we have the wave three
nhs guidance that was issued around the
starting up of electives
and managing winter and and also adult
social care winter plan
and both of these and we need to fully
respond to
um on our collective plan by the 31st of
october
and we've got some core issues so winter
is always very busy
um around particularly around flu around
admissions around
falls around respiratory issues but on
top of that obviously this year we've
got the covid
and the second spike that we're
experiencing at the moment
and to add into the mix and we've also
got
um the point that sally made very well
then around
people accessing and support generally
and advice and guidance early enough
screening
and restarting and the elective care
restarting as well
and the desire across the whole system
and the country to keep that elective
care running through winter
and we have done modeling
on all of the um information that we are
uh
privy to around the activity from march
through
to now and forecasting based on national
um modelling around the impacts of the
second wave
and we've used that to then look at the
capacity requirements across all of the
types of services that we're offering
including health and social care
settings primary care etc
and we've made a commitment to one plan
we don't want to do three plans and send
them up to three different um
bodies that need them so we are
combining this into one plan
which the presentation details we have
set out
our pathways particularly around covid
response we have um
protocols and pathways for our general
responses through
health and social care but we have done
a set of pathways which you can click on
in the presentation
it takes you to the detail and those
have recently been refreshed based on a
lessons learnt process
and on what we've experienced
from march onwards those pathways cover
a discharge
from hospital which continues under the
guidance to require
you to step into somewhere either that's
your own home or
a base solution in the community once
you are fit to leave hospital
and it covers respiratory support
being safe at home in the support that
we offer into people's homes
supporting to care homes end-of-life
support
and support when children and adults
need to access services where they may
are suspected of being covered positive
and um quite new and emerging work
around
the the impacts that kovid has on
somebody in the long term and services
that will be needed to be stacked up
and as we as more people are recovering
from covid
and we use our recovery and reform group
which you will have on the
agenda as for later updates to track
the work that we're doing and
particularly the work that we're
expanding
over the winter the plan is absolutely
jointly commissioned and developed
through all of our services and all
partners are
really supportive in bringing this to
life
the operating model for the system is in
place
and which we have enhanced based on
recent guidance
the hospital discharge guidance is still
operational
it has been amended slightly but it does
still require people to leave hospital
within three hours
of becoming fit to leave and it also
does inc
require testing before discharge if your
destination is to a care home
we have a single coordinator in place
we've utilized our urgent care control
room which we are
very lucky in traffic to have been
running down for a couple of years so
we've got a lot of experience there
they track everybody who needs support
and out of hospital to their destination
and then follows that
up over a six-week period to ensure the
right services going into place
and
we we are experiencing a very different
pattern so in the first
part of the work with kovid people were
in hospital
were very very poorly and were not fit
for discharge
until probably eight to ten weeks after
admission
and therefore their testing on discharge
was usually
negative testing before discharge
however we're now
experiencing younger people being
admitted to hospital and their recovery
is faster
and therefore the government has issued
guidance recently on having a designated
site for anyone who is kv-positive
we've done a lot of work on this and
went out to tend to some
um provision that hasn't been as
successful as we'd like so we've entered
into agreements and negotiations with
manchester
to have a joint side in manchester and
that will be
progressed over the next couple of weeks
we currently have
60 um discharge to assess beds which are
commissioned across our um
care home provision and which are being
very well utilized
and those contracts are being renewed
and extended
we've got rapid discharge home care
services
that are again being renewed for this
next phase
and we have our therapy provision to
support people on discharge
we're tracking the capacity required and
on a on a daily basis and matching that
against our forecasting so if we need to
step up services
in a different way we are we are seeing
early signs of that
we're using a lot of digital solutions
to support people where possible
to ensure that we can keep track of
everyone and they've got access to
support
in the latest guidance um there is a
change in the way personal protective
equipment will be offered and that will
be sourced through a national
portal and it will be free and
to registered and unregistered services
we are we have a hub between manchester
and trafford that has supplied
our ppe and which is being led by
eleanor's team and very effectively we
are going to keep that in place
for the foreseeable future um as a
backup
and supports that process our care homes
are contacted twice a week and that will
continue through winter
and we're tracking all outbreaks our
infection control team
with lms support go in if we have any
notifications in any care homes both for
staff and residents
weekly testing is in place for residents
and care homes and
sorry for staff in care homes and
monthly testing for residents in care
homes and
we have obviously a number of risks
through the winter which as
elena has described continue to increase
with the
outbreak um extending but we
are confident that we have captured
those in our plan and have plans to spot
things early and
make changes where required for our
programming the other big risk i would i
would escalate
so that you are fully aware of is the
cost
of the second spike so all services are
under significant pressure
there is changing in the funding um
arrangements in that the first six weeks
of support post discharge will be
funded through the nhs and after that
the the cost will move
um back to social care that does place
pressure on the council's budgets and
but we are tracking that
and monitoring that and working
nationally with leaders
and with the minister to flag up those
and potential risks
i'll finish their chair hopefully that's
i'm giving people a flavor of the winter
plan
thank you diane and does anybody have
any questions around the winter planning
our preparation uh going forward
nothing in the chat um thank you
thank you day after that and so if we
move on
and elena is there anything more that
you want to say about the public
engagement board or
no just really that um it meets
fortnightly and we're really keen to
make sure that the work of that board is
is reaching everybody in trafford we've
got a sub board that supports the work
and actually we've had really good
coverage as well from the evening news
and other
press up from that board which i think
is incredibly helpful
so i'd like to thank them for that um
because it's just really about how we
get their messaging out to people but
also
how we hear from people which we're
picking up and we'll be reporting back
on that
on that board thank you very much and so
we'll move on to item eight then and
thanks for stepping back in tom it's
over to you thank you very much
good good morning everyone um
is someone able to share the slide or um
am i able to share my screen and fly to
it myself
is that easier you can try something
it's easier if you can do it um because
then you know when to scroll through but
if you're not able to
then i'll put them up let me uh
i'll try now and hopefully i will be
fine
you just bear with me one second
hopefully this should work has that
worked
uh yes i can think can everyone else see
yeah i can see
i can't hear tom now though
yeah i i can't hear anything either
tom you seem to be muted or something
we can't hear anything that you're
saying
[Music]
okay i just stopped i'm sharing just in
the hopes that we can get him back and
i can hear him again
[Music]
i haven't used my powers
[Music]
tommy you able to leave and come back
[Music]
i wonder if it's possible and if i could
fill the time just ask a quick question
about the last
thing we talked about um so i just
wanted to ask um i know that there was
some mention of um
therapy provision going in for people
for discharging out of hospital
and i i know that the one-stop resource
center a lot of the occupational
therapists there have been
moved over to fill that some of that
capacity there
and then we've been having some
difficulties um accessing provision that
would normally be
supplied through the one stop resource
center i just wondered if anybody had
any
a bit more information about that or
when those services might
be up and running again
shall i take that chair
[Music]
thank you rebecca and what we were
discussing this at our local care
alliance meeting yesterday and we're
going to reissue the guidance across the
system
um as to contact and service offering
each of our services
if there's any specific issues rebecca
if you could just drop me a line
and i'll follow them up and pick them up
for you great thank you very much thank
you
[Music]
you put in the chat that you wanted to
ask a question do you want to
ask that question now
um i think i just made a couple of
points
uh chair regarding i thought diane's
reassurance around the winter plan was
was uh
very comprehensive and although there
are lots of challenges
there's a lot of forward thinking about
how to meet those challenges which is
really reassuring
what i'm not sure about is what we have
around children and young people and i
know
i wouldn't expect diane to cover that in
her presentation but i think as a board
some more reassurance around what's
happening with our children and young
people because i'd said in an earlier
comment too when we were talking about
when sally mentioned
the impact on mental health that we do
know
and i think this is a national issue
that the mental health of children and
young people
is extremely vulnerable at the moment
and i think as a board
something around reassurance around
what's happening in
schools to address that this is not only
the responsibility of schools of course
we all have a role to play but um i
think we we were getting some
reassurance around a very robust and
solid plan around adults
i'm sure jill if she were able to join
us this morning would be
championing the children and young
people element of those plans as well
um i agree with that at that point if
and
jill has been able to attend we would
have most probably been able to give you
some
further update around and children's
services so
if we can make a note of that alex and
perhaps bring something back to the
next board or share something with board
members i can see heather you want to
come in
uh yes please um there have been um
some uh deep dives in terms of
children's services
undertaken by the equality finance and
performance board and i understand that
a further
update is going to be available in
december
so uh accept everything that's said
about
um you know a bit more information about
children's service but want to give an
assurance that
in fact and that work is currently being
done
thank you very much for that and maureen
you're happy with that i can see thank
you and
it looks like tom isn't on the call
rebecca did you want to come back in
with something else
sorry yeah i just um wanted to raise
something really practical
so um a lot of the advice that we've
heard already this morning is about
utilizing outdoor space meeting outdoors
um but i have two very young children
myself so i have a one-year-old and a
three-year-old and one thing i've
noticed recently in trafford
is that a lot of the outdoor play
equipment is in really poor condition
or in fact just not usable at all and
um obviously with the winter months
coming up and infection rates increasing
i'm very conscious as a parent i don't
want to take my children to any indoor
play centers to those outdoor
play centers are a huge resource at the
moment and i wondered whether we could
um prompt the right people in the
necessary areas to perhaps take a look
at some of those
outdoor play areas and i'm aware that we
have
had to close the children's play area in
longford park and have been an accident
there so and that's why
that has been um closed and it's going
to be repaired
and i know that it's in a plan of work
to um
be done and hopefully we you know if we
can we will get that brought forward but
um one traffic are working on our parks
and trying to get you know
the budget ball equipment so that
children's play areas are
still operable over the over the winter
months so yeah
we are aware of that and and i'm i'm
more than happy to speak to
um councillor patel and ask her to come
back to you rebecca um
or if you want to contact councillor
patel
and and uh you know raise any direct
points with her and she'll be able to
respond to you
and yes please oh linda wants to come in
but yes please diane
when we finish this last question if you
can start with tom's because it looks
like we've lost him
yeah okay could i just concur what's
been said um david yoon park
the play area has been chained up for
six months
and i've been told no idea when it's
going to be reopened
and i've seen children climbing over
the chained up thing onto the damaged
equipment
and um amy had been informed about this
but
nothing again nothing seems to be
happening and it's
uh you know it's just a great resource
that
is not being used so i just wanted to
bring that up thank you
thank you thank you linda like i said
and i think that
amy has got a plan of works um and
hopefully we can
get them to do some of the play
equipment sooner rather than later but
it's something if you want to raise with
um councillor patel who will be able to
respond to you but thanks okay diane it
doesn't look like we've got tom back so
if you want to
carry on please thank you chad i'm just
wondering if thomas dialed in
no okay uh he is uh i have spoken to him
on the phone and he's going to dial in
in a moment he's there trying to access
um by using another
device at the moment as well okay but i
can share the
presentation if you'd like and then go
through it please that would be really
helpful
we'll attempt to to start it as soon as
tom's in
hopefully he'll take back over if we go
on to the second slide
for me please and as you as you
know previously we've brought here we
have now got a full running program
on our recovery under reform for health
and social care in line with the
locality plan
and it's broken down into four main
projects and the first one living well
in my community
really um starts to bring to life the
work that we've seen developing
and delivered really well and with the
community and voluntary sector
over the kovu period and the group
leaders are um have now agreed four
key areas which you can see their
development in place-based working
and the partnership on wider information
and advice which is going to be crucial
as we move into these next
few months with with the impact on
businesses and employment
and promoting equality by reducing
health inequalities
and a stronger and healthier voluntary
sector in trafford which really starts
to set us up for a sustained voluntary
sector moving forward
and they have um
had several workshops which have brought
all of the groups together
it's a very very well provisioned
voluntary sector
very extensive some really um amazing
work that's already delivered and the
vast amount of experience
and and they have come together and set
out a
deliverable program if we go on to the
next slide
please and there you can see each of
these
work programs now have deliverables
um in a three-month stint because
obviously we have another spike
that we're dealing with and we want to
make sure that staff are able to manage
the changes
that we're trying to put in place
particularly important for this work
stream is the fact that it is
absolutely co-produced with our
sector i think we've gone forward on a
slide just go back one
thank you and and you can see some of
it now if we can go just go back a
couple we seem to have jumped forward
diane i'm back if you i don't know
whether anyone thank you tom
i was just just on in my community just
on the and three months
um deliverables all right okay
fantastic i'm not too sure that i'm
having to sign in on my phone i think
i've swapped three rooms so far to try
and get better access
and gone on about three different
devices so i do apologize to uh to
colleagues
um not wanting to maybe go over some of
what you've got uh
what you've already done diana and i
don't know how much sort of context you
set for colleagues but
if we if i take it read that you've done
some context and i'll just jump in at
the start of living well in my community
is that about right yeah yes please
okay great thank you um so i think as
probably diane's mentioned we have now
four collaborative
um strategic design groups working
across health and social care
which pulls in all the work that was
diane that was diane was describing
earlier around around the new pathways
around covid response
and the winter plan and the nhs recovery
element as well in terms of responding
to the
um the asks of the nhs and all that is
weaved through these inclusive strategic
design groups
and some of them particularly living
well in my community
he's really really representative of the
wider health and social care system
across the borough
with a roundabout at the moment 18
different partners all co-producing what
those priorities will be
and how we will deliver them um with
obviously within the resources that
we've got available to us
um i wasn't going to go through each of
the individual strategic design groups
and highlight all of the work that's
happening because there's so much
and it's fantastic to see but what these
slides hopefully do is give some
assurance that
there is a a very defined set of
priorities for each of those strategic
design groups
they have joint chairs um who are
working together across the ccg the
council
and our wider partners so living well in
my community has uh george devlin and
roger sutton
um from the volunteering and faith
sector uh as co-chairs of that
particular strategic design group
weaving into the other governance in in
the trafford system in terms of
inclusive growth and stronger
communities
because we do realize that we want to
build our trafford together locality
plan which we produced at the back end
of last year
and which is about not just doing the
the day-to-day health and social care
support services which is evidently so
important
but also that longer term prevention and
tackling health inequalities
in our borough um i i can't necessarily
see the slides on my phone on what
slides you're on so i'll just
sort of talk to some of these and
hopefully you can pick up and move the
slides
forward accordingly if you can that'd be
really helpful um
so each of the strategic design groups
has a road map
um and the roadmap describes what we're
going to do in sort of the next
12 weeks essentially over the course of
september october november
and probably into december now as these
get updated in the next couple of weeks
so there's some real tangible pieces of
work there in each of the strategic
design groups
around information and advice around
working with the volunteer community
sector to understand the funding and
developing that inclusive
sort of growth strategy and to to spend
that money differently and more wisely
for better outcomes
there's work highlighted on um some of
the road maps in future slides
and in living well in living well at
home and a step closer to home around
technology-enabled care
uh rapid home care maximizing social
value impacts of
of home care as well in the borough and
then some real specific tangible
programs of work around how we're going
to step back up and recover
from a health perspective around
community rehab uh the changes in urgent
care
by appointment and under long-term
conditions reform
um that again is being co-produced with
our key colleagues across mft gmmh
and all the other health providers that
we commission with in the system
as well as working closely closely with
the primary care networks as part of
um our place-based approach to health
and social care
and so there's a lot of priorities
they're all detailed in the role maps
and more than happy to take any
questions on some of the specifics
as we move through and to the end of the
slides and all follow-up conversations
if required with colleagues
um is there anything down that you would
like to uh
bear in mind i missed five minutes at
the beginning there i do apologize
thank you tom we've worked really hard
and tom has worked to set up
um behind this an engagement and
communication strategy
which links across with ellen's work
around the covid
engagement work as well to make sure
that we're really hearing from people
and as we move through this uh work
and and at pace and often you can not
remember to get the views of people and
the outcomes and changes that you're
making and the impact
so the other work that tom is leading is
to um
ensure that we've got a performance a
framework that sits behind this so that
we can
really see deliverables and many members
have asked
over the period of the development of
this work
is how we will show those outcomes so
and
we will have quite tangible uh results
for you to
to scrutinize at a later date
dan i think we've got some and we've got
a number of slides in the pack that
describes some of the work that's
ongoing with regards to company
engagement and measurement framework if
i
if uh if people um if i work through
those and then we pause for some
comments is that okay chair at the end
that's great thank you tom thank you so
if i move on to communications and
engagement strategy
um i know that we circulated the full
strategy document which was
20 something pages long and so not
wanting to go through that but what we
have done is put together a few
short slides to pull out the key parts
of that and it picks up the points made
by owen before around this is around one
strategy one communications and
engagement strategy for health and
social care across the borough
that is very importantly placed in two
core components
and one to deal with covid which is the
here and the now and how we manage
messaging how we get messaging out in a
quick and a targeted way
and also that engagement where that
proactive engagement work to try and
stop the spread
and educate people as to the rules and
behaviours that are required for us to
work through this
and come out the other side in the best
position possible but it is also to have
one eye to the future as we said in our
traffic to the locality plan
this is about the building blocks for
the next five years to do that whole
piece around co-production
to encourage that social movement and to
do that really
joined up proactive comes around really
key um issues within our borough
whether it be around suicide prevention
whether it be around flu
etc etc and so all that work is is tied
into this one strategy
and in terms of the strategy itself and
there are some slides and i think it's
on the next slide
um from what i can see in the very small
screen of my uh
phone but there are core components of
the strategy i won't go through each one
of those but as you can imagine
um they're all really important parts of
the strategy making sure that the
governance right making sure
that the resourcing of the program is
appropriate so that we can actually do
the work that we aspire to do and not
setting on unachievable aims and
objectives
and next to each of those core
components of the strategy is our
commitment
and when i say our commitment this is a
group that's been meeting now for nine
months
um so there is a steering group that
sits behind it and it's detailed in in
the flow chart in a minute
of where that sits but that's made up of
18 or 19 different organizations from
trafford housing trust
to the primary care networks to dwp to
the council the cctg and so many other
partners
and it's it's a big thank you from me
actually for their uh for their
continued engagement in that group
and they are the people that have drove
uh drove the strategy forward
and they are now fully included within
the very practical groups
um the virtual comms network and the
engagement forum
which is about doing that real tangible
work on the ground with their networks
with their patients with the public
and so that's a big big thank you and if
we just move on another
couple of there you go yeah you've uh
you've just gone over the connectivity
and i won't spend too much time on that
but that just shows how the system is
connecting
and how that reports into here in terms
of health and well-being board
so very aligned in terms of local care
alliance public
engagement board and the health
protection board with the governance
sat underneath that that drives all the
work and that ellen has mentioned
earlier on and
diane alluded to evaluation and making
sure that we understand whether or not
we've made a difference and
that is absolutely keen i'll touch on
that in a little bit more detail in a
short space
um but what we're saying is these are
some of the things that we will use in
order to
understand whether or not we made a
difference so we will continue to get
that feedback from individuals from from
our stakeholders as well
we will maximize the use of digital
surveys appropriately and
proportionately
and we will understand our reach in
terms of social media and and print
media as well
um as well as using online analytical
tools as well so we will be able to keep
track and that steering group will be a
pivotal forum as to whether or not we
are reaching our intended audiences
um the next slides um were originally i
think item 11 on the agenda
and we wanted to cover these um in the
meeting now i i was led to believe
someone was going to come in and cover
um future trafford but i'm not sure
anyone's been able to join us
so i'm i'm happy to just cover these
slides quickly and make people aware of
the progress made on future traffic if
that's okay
unless there's someone on the call who
can jump in who's been more involved
than myself
yeah okay thank you um so future
for the hashtag futuretrafford hopefully
people will be familiar
um with the campaign i think we are in
phase one of the campaign so you can
click to the
the next slide and there are four
focuses of of future offering and this
is really around
understanding where do we want you know
what are we trying to do here in
trafford
what do you see your future in trafford
as um and
that's really sort of blue sky thinking
what do we want for our future of
ourselves but our families our friends
our communities
and there's a number of different themes
within the within the campaign over four
weeks which around employment skills
business recovery
children and young people and then
living well in my community which brings
that link back to the work we're doing
in the strategic design group
and which again i think shows that level
of collaboration across partners
and it has been a
partnership approach this campaign with
the campaign development being led by
trafford housing trust
and the management being done by the
council in terms of the campaign
management
so this is really about maximum reach
and making sure that we can interact and
get as much feedback as we possibly can
from people across trafford and then
that will help shape our recovery plans
not just for the immediate future but
for the long term
and so how do we change trafford to take
on board what people
have said um really at this stage
um having not been involved directly in
the campaign i think it's a great thing
to do
this sort of gives us a really um good
opportunity to engage with a wide
audience through lots of different media
channels
in order to shape the long-term recovery
plan that traffic partnership as a board
is pushing
um and my plea at this point would be
that if everyone can get behind these
campaigns
on a weekly basis engaging social media
as much as you can through your
respective networks
that would be fantastic
thank you and then lastly i think my my
last
update would be on the health and social
care recovery and reform measurement
framework which diane just
very quickly alluded to before um
so we always have the challenge don't we
of of
understanding whether or not we've made
a difference to people's lives and i
think that was the real sort of plain
language that we use within our traffic
together locality plan
and it's fine counting widgets as people
say
um but actually we want to hear stories
we need to understand whether or not
we've made a difference to people's
lives by doing things differently in
health and care
and what we're proposing to do is is
build on the existing products and
dashboards and data and intelligence
that we have and pull that into one
central place so that as a local care
alliance
and as a health and well-being board we
can work together to understand
what is changing across health and
social care and and that might be around
specific
measurable things around how many people
do x y or z
but it is also about that quality of
qualitative level of information as well
which over the course of covid has been
phenomenal you know the
the the plethora of information and
intelligence we've got through surveys
and through the likes of the vcsc um
collective doing their service through
thrive as well the community hubs
all that is really rich intelligence by
which we need to then
um commission differently deliver
differently um and co-produce
differently um
moving forward so you'll see a list of
existing products and
dashboards that are there currently and
what we're proposing to do is sort of
minimize them where it makes sense that
streamline that so we understand
what parts of the system these reports
are going into and for what reason
um so whether or not it is for assurance
or whether or not it's for continuous
quality improvement so we can understand
whether or not we need to make changes
to pathways we need to commission
different or new services etc etc or
whether or not we need to invest more in
one part of the system
than another and so how we move that
money around
and moving on the next slide a little
bit of a colorful slide oh yeah sorry
just moved back i couldn't quite see it
and thank you very much
and so this colorful slide here with a
bit of a framework in it starts to
take us back to our aspirations of our
locality planner and better lives for
our most vulnerable people
um better well-being for all our
population and better connections
throughout our communities
and and what we're intending on doing
over the course of the next few weeks
and taking to our
november local carolinas board it's a
populated version of this it will look
it will look a lot nicer than this um
but it will be a populated version
with real data and intelligence and
information in there
that will give us an understanding
whether or not we are making a
difference and reducing our health
inequality whether or not we are
recovering as we say we want to
uh from covid and and how we're going to
reform our system and do things
differently
it also picks up some of the really
important parts for me and it's how
important our workforce has been over
this last nine months and how important
it will be moving forward
across health and social care and and
beyond but understanding whether or not
we have productive
and happy staff um who are doing the
best that they can do is a really
important
measure that we need to build into this
so is the finance because we all work
within a
you know within finite budgets and we
know how pressured the system is in
terms of money
and therefore we have to do this with
with with money in mind and maximize the
traffic pound is what we're trying to do
here and again that goes back to our
commitment
in the original locality plan and we
have to retain our focus on safe and
high quality services
so what we will be doing over the course
of the coming weeks and be great to come
back to this board and share
um the lca measurement framework with
you in due course
is using the dashboards that we've got
understanding the information we've got
and what
what level of data that is at um i'm
bringing that back into
a dashboard that is for the health and
social care system that everyone
understands
and so we understand whether or not
we're we're making
improvements or where we've got room for
improvement still and that will all be
based on the foundation
of what our neighborhoods look like and
feel like what are our needs and assets
in neighborhoods so there is a piece of
work handling at the moment
to develop those neighborhood profiles
and and to build everything
on that joint strategic needs assessment
so we're addressing those inequalities
as we referred to on a number of
occasions
and that's probably enough from me at
this point i think the things on the
final slide i think i've covered
i think the one thing maybe i didn't
make made clear is that
the strategic design groups from health
and social care that we we talked about
earlier
and they are integral to this the work
flows through those groups
and therefore the measurement frameworks
that exist in those strategic design
groups
will form a key component of this local
care alliance measurement framework once
we
once we get it published and it'd be
great to bring that back nearer the end
of the calendar year
thank you so much tom that was really
helpful and it actually
shows you know the locality plan that we
bought back in 2019
actually in action and how it can adapt
when we are faced with
um you know the big issue that we've got
now around covid and you know the stuff
that you've been talking about
about the trafford pound and social
value is really really important we need
to keep
our money and and you know see our see
our communities thrive so thank you so
much for that
i do know that maureen has already
indicated that she has a question and
then if other people would like to ask
questions i've got another
person after that so maureen do you want
to go ahead
yeah thanks shane i've actually put it
into chat so i mean if you want to do it
via that route that's absolutely fine
it just struck me looking through um
that really uh helpful presentation
the um strong focus on health and social
care obviously
and getting the intelligence around that
but
but we know in relation to people's
feelings of
of safety and well-being there are much
wider determinants of that
too and and so i was wondering really
how are we capturing
those things um is that
embedded into the neighborhood profile
if you will in the neighborhood
intelligence so how
you know and how are we using police
intelligence for example
um so just just didn't
didn't spring out at me there tom from
the presentation that you give i'm sure
it's there
but i'd be really interested to know how
we're getting hold of that
because sometimes what we think and what
people
are thinking on a day-to-day basis and
are not the same
they're determined by other factors
really helpful if i could come back at
that um so thank you very much maureen
and and yes it is absolutely our
intention to make sure that this isn't
just simply about
information that resides in health and
social care but he's from the wider
system so
a key piece of work we've done recently
from um
and it's from eight different sources of
uh
surveys face-to-face interviews before
uh restrictions came in for online focus
groups
and and that was the the voluntary
community sector pulling that together
in some cases
we've had uh the healthwatch survey and
the interim version
of that has been taken to our health and
social care recovery reform board
with some fantastic information in there
that was which we were unaware of
you know at certain points and what
we're trying to do is build all that
information in
and that for me becomes part of this
measurement framework it has to
it has to intrinsically go through the
strategic design group so that
information
affects how we commission how we deliver
how we how we co-produce and what those
services will look like
um we did and it's still work in
progress but we did say that
um we we had a commitment around i
statements within our traffic to get a
locality plan
and they're very broad ranging and
actually when you read them they're not
just about health and social care
they're about having a good life
being a good neighbor being a good
citizen how you help others how you stay
connected
and what we need to do is what is work
with um the group that we have convened
around
um at the moment by nature it's pulling
together the business intelligence
analytical capacity in the council and
the ccg to understand what data and
information we have
but very soon what we want to do is open
that conversation out
and then start to think about well how
do we measure progress against these i
statements because
the police will have intelligence dwp
will have intelligence and our wider
partners will as well and
it's the information that we won't have
readily available to us we'll have to
cross ig barriers and things like that
because that will inevitably get in the
way to some degree
and but it is absolutely a commitment
that we that's what we want to do
there's a really useful presentation
which i'm sure it'd be worth sharing
and which pulls together the eight
sources of learning from the kobit
period
and and we could share that as a really
good resource because it all resonate
with everyone from their own respective
organizations
thank you tom is that okay maureen yeah
it is thanks thanks chair a a really
helpful
response i suppose the the other thing
i've mentioned i've mentioned them
already today
is schools and and to try and weave that
more um more visibly in
into the information that we're putting
out because again it's so important
and linda do you want to come in yes
uh thanks tom your presentations are
great very very informative
can i ask on a practical level is there
a central resource that has a glossary
of acronyms that can be used as a link
for any meetings we have so that
we don't have to ask at every meeting
what what does this stand for is is this
possible
i'm just i'm just thinking it it'll save
a lot of
time and in the future
that's what councillor freeman has been
asking for quite some time
linda so hopefully we will get one you
will absolutely you will absolutely get
one and we
literally had the conversation this week
it's nearly finalized
along with some of the sub-governance
not necessarily for this membership of
this group but
those two things are going to go hand in
hand and be one document that explains
the sub governance between the strategy
underneath sorry the strategic design
groups and where those informal and
formal meetings are happening really
driving the work forward
but also that glossary that says this is
what this
acronym means so we will absolutely send
that out and probably
post that in various different places so
people can have access to it
um because i do appreciate we we try to
fit so much on slides we end up
defaulting back to um acronyms and we
shouldn't do so
thank you for raising it thank you
thanks for that tom thanks for diane
stepping in there
when we couldn't get started um if we
can move on now to item
10 and here you go let eleanor explain
this acronym
cdop report eleanor thank you very much
apollo geez for the acronym this is the
child death overview panel which
is um the child death overview panel is
the group that um reviews
every death of any child between um
birth and 18 years um we've
had child death overview panels now in
this country for i would say about 10
years
so we're getting quite a substantial
data set
um the aim of the cdot is to make sure
that any learning
from any any child death is is um
embedded into future service delivery
and to look and see whether there are
any preventable
preventation messages that we can take
and apply to the population
um because obviously you know any child
death is
is deeply tragic and very very hard for
any family to get over so we really do
want to make sure
that we um we learn anything we can from
those
from those cases and sometimes as well
with with some of the cases
um sorry with some cases it is that
sometimes it's not only about
prevention prevent not every death can
be prevented
but sometimes um particularly in cases
of serious illness for example or long
a long-standing condition sometimes it's
making sure that
the death is as good as possible as it
can be for that child and for that
family
um so the this proposal you've seen
reports from the cwc.now reports into
the health and wellbeing board
um and this is simply a request for the
health and well-being boards to
raise awareness to the health and
well-being board that we're suggesting
changing the method that we
manage these um that we manage
the um recording and the
um uh sorry distracted by the phone
um that we um have a
better system of managing the process
for recording and sharing the
information on the desks
so it's um a request to spend some of
the money that isn't being spent
currently
on having an independent chair because
that role has been picked up through the
public health team
and to use that money to set up and um
this ec
system uh maureen has sent i think she's
not on call anymore but she has sent
a question through oh sorry warren you
are on the call
and yes it will it will make it easier i
think to do all of our statutory
requirements in relation to the cdoc
so it's effectively just an
administrative change but we're asking
for approval
are board members happy with that change
thank you agreed elena thank you
i think maury wants to come in with a
question just very quickly chair and i
did put something up for eleanor right
at the start of this meeting
uh this is the first site we've had of
this paper
and it has been discussed with greater
manchester safeguarding board chairs but
in brief
and i would just welcome the opportunity
to take a brief
offline conversation with eleanor just
to ensure
that there's one element of child death
which is very much
linked to the safeguarding system and
that's where there has been
significant harm because of abuse and we
need to be
absolutely clear that any new
arrangement
ties into the rapid review of those
cases
which still sits within the domain of
strategic safeguarding partnerships
i know ellen is completely aware of that
and
she wouldn't be putting forward a paper
that hadn't thought about that but i
would just welcome
that opportunity to have a five-minute
chat with ellen about ensuring our
systems are lined up
absolutely happy with that yeah we don't
want to do anything that
destabilizes that part of the system
it's absolutely critical
thank you all thank you maury and
i think that actually now brings us to
the end of the
um
we've got the presentation on the
strategic objectives of the board
sorry i was just trying to rush us on
i'm so sorry i missed that and it's over
to you eleanor again i'm so sorry
thanks so this is i don't know alex if
you can put up the presentation and i'll
ask um
so this is really just give an
opportunity for the border the last
couple of meetings of the board we have
been
very focused on on covert and our
response to covid understandably
um but i think from the conversations
that we've had at the meeting today we
are
trying to now get away from just
thinking covert response and starting to
think about how do we get our recovery
work going and as diane said a lot of
and tom's work are absolutely and
the winter plan is all about responding
but also planning for a better response
and the work that tom and diane were
describing about how we're actually
going to be working together more
effectively
across the whole system is again very
much embedded in that
what how we're going to make sure that
we get better services
for the future and make sure that our
services are more responsive to our
population needs
so we have been over the last um
since as you all remember our goals for
the health and well-being board have
always been about improving healthy life
expectancy
and making sure that we limit we reduce
the gap
in inequalities on that measure
bienish who i would like to introduce
you
here i'm here hi beanish so i'm going to
ask to talk
about this in a minute but i think what
we've beenish has been um
as i don't know we've um our public
health
uh danish is um
a new appointment to the team and
covering the public health data
analytics function
and we're absolutely delighted to have
her she has been spending a lot of the
last um since she started a month ago
she's been updating all of our systems
to make sure that our data is absolutely
up to date and we've got our jsna data
um in a state that tom and others who
need to use it
are able to use it but one of the things
we've lost at the moment is i think
we've got some good news
for us on our healthy life expectancy
measures you'll remember that we talked
about obesity
about physical inactivity about smoking
and alcohol
we've got some good news for the data
that we're seeing that
bienish will quickly run through um but
some of the measures i'll a only go up
to 2018
and we really need to be thinking about
how we get quick data sets in to see
what has happened what's been the impact
of coded on all of this
the other issue we have is on some
measures for example healthy life
expectancy
we don't have it by deprivation and
we're not a
we're not able to do that analysis of
the deprivation link with our healthy
life expectancy at the moment
so again this is something that bienish
is going to be looking into to see that
we can
manage that better the other things i
would just mention are sometimes we do
fine
against the england average but
sometimes that's because the england
average is shocking
so the fact that so many people are
inactive and so many people
are overweight is going to build
problems in for us not only in our kogit
response but obviously
in the need for health services and so
on in the future but
so it's just to to so but there is
actually for a miracle there is some
good news in the slides that beanish
will just quickly run through
so bienish can i hand over to you
she has said that her connection is
quite bad ellen and so i'm not sure
and you shall i i'll um
shall i just quickly spin through the
slides then so what we've seen
is that the our healthy life expectancy
is increasing across
both males and females which is really
good news
and it's actually increased slightly so
that is brilliant
however we need to be looking at how we
measure that internal inequalities on
that
i'm working with i think our ccg
colleagues on some proxy measures for
that
to make sure that we're able to be
confident that we're seeing that
um that change in all of our community
um and the next slide
so this is healthy life expectancy and
this is against our statistical
neighbors
sorry just going and sorry just one back
[Music]
um coming a bit weird
my screen it is a bit weird i don't know
if it's weird on everyone's screens yes
it's just like there's a huge black
um missing part on it is everyone having
the same thing
yeah yes i
okay luckily i think people have the
slides in their packs so we can um
tell the story and people will will be
able to fill in the missing gaps
yes so um healthy life expectancy for
both male and females been increasing
um from two uh from 2013
to 2015 it's been increasing more for
males i'm sorry i cannot see
cannot see the female sign there's a big
but
generally the story is the healthy life
expectancy is increasing across
trafford for both males and females
especially over the last
four years um can we move go to the next
slide please
oh yeah it's the same thing um
so um across trafford has one of the
highest life expectancy in males 66
years
and we compare it to the statistical
neighbors for trafford for the period
2016 to 2018
which is the latest data we have
available it ranks second to
south south gloucestershire sorry i'm
really
67.3 years so if we can go to the next
site please
uh for the females as well uh traffic
again has one of the highest
life expectancies which is 66 years and
this time it reads
ranks third to its uh statistical
neighbors who has the highest of 66.5
years
uh this is all this data is for 2016 to
2018 which is the latest we have
available
from the public health outcomes
framework can we have the next slide
please
so um we want to reduce harm from
smoking so adult smoking prevalence in
traffic has been declining from 16.4
percent
in 2015 to 9.1 uh
in 2019 this is lower than the average
for england
the biggest change that we have seen is
the smoking prevalence in routine and
manual worker with there's been a sharp
decline
from 26.4 in 2018
to 17.4 in 2019
and when we compared it to england it's
statistically similar to england as a
benchmark
and amongst the group of local
authorities trafford now has the lowest
prevalence of smoking in routine and
manual workers
and when we looked at it previously
trafford had one of the highest ones and
now over the past few years especially
um
in 2019 the rates are the lowest so
that's something very promising
um can we have the next slide please um
oh i can't see this i can't see the
heading for this one
i think it's a routine of manual workers
the same one where we can see
that uh it has been uh the rates the
smoking uh
uh the prevalence for smoking the
percentage has been declining over the
years
and especially like i said earlier from
2018 there's been a very sharp decline
in
smoking in the manual and the routine
working class
um can we go on to the next slide please
so another one is reducing harm from
alcohol
so 28 percent of adults in trafford are
drinking above the recommended
levels we are seeing a high
increasing rates of alcohol related
hospitalizations this is especially for
conditions uh where alcohol is the same
cause
when we looked at premature mortalities
or mortality under 75 years of age from
liver disease in trafford we saw that it
was
worse and again this was statistically
significant
when we compared it for england for the
period 2013 to 2015.
this is the latest data we have so
whatever we are presenting is the latest
data that's available
and when we looked at a group of 15
similar authorities for premature
mortality from liver diseases trafford
ranked the worst
but um uh when uh
then from 2016 to sorry
there is latest date available i'm sorry
i missed that line excuse me
so from 2016 17 to 18 premature
mortality from liver
disease in trafford is decreasing and is
similar statistically significant to
england i'm really sorry i missed this
part
can we go on to the next slide so in
summary um premature mortality from
liver diseases
over the past three five three years for
which we have the data which is 2016
17 and 18 premature mortality is
reducing and we can see it in this graph
as well from the same period when we go
down to 2016 17 and 18 there's a slight
spike in 2017 but then again it's going
down
so it would be good to see data more
recent data for 19 uh 2019 and of course
for 2020.
um can we go on to the next slide please
so um another one is reduced physical uh
inactivity
so three out of every five adults in
trafford
are overweight or obese that's around 64
percent
so uh prevalence of overweight including
obesity
in reception is 19.9 and this is
lower than average for england which is
24.4 percent
then again in year six as well trafford
uh prevalence of overweight and that we
also include obesity here
is 31.6 percent and is again lower
than 35.9 percent in england
so uh when we look at overweight and
including obesity
traffic ranks amongst the best for the
low prevalence of overweight and obesity
um in 2000 uh sorry my
screens sorry about that it just
disappears
so uh the latest data for 2018 and 2019
suggests that
uh in trafford 19 of adults
are physically uh inactive and this was
again statistically similar to england
as a benchmark
however the level of physical inactivity
has been declining
from the year 2015 to 2016
uh to present um
sorry so
uh when you look at this data here as
well you can see that uh
the level of inactive adults when we
look across across 2015 to 2016 to now
it's there's been a decline uh
so can we go to the next i'm sorry um my
screen's just getting very weird so if i
just go quiet for a minute
it's um because there's something coming
on my screen can we go to the next slide
please
this in this slide we're looking at a
prevalence of obesity
in uh your six jewels school children
across various deprivation quintiles
so quintile one is uh um
this method is uh got um the most
deprived quintile
which is the one in the left and as you
go down each quintile and level five
quintile five is the uh least deprived
so uh when we look at it you can see
there is a gradient
kind of a social gradient when we look
uh across prevalence of obesity
in year six school children and those in
the most deprived
quantile are twice uh
there's a pr prevalence is two times
higher in those in the most deprived
quintile compared with the least
deprived quintile
26 versus 13 percent in the least
deprived quintile can we go to the next
slide please
um then again if you look by uh sorry
some of the values are missing but when
we look
by in reception years you can see again
that those in the most
deprived quintile this the prevalence is
twice
uh two times more uh
which is 13 in the most uh deprived
quintile compared with the least
deprived quintile where that is six
percent
um can we go to the next slide please
so here we're talking about improving
cancer prevention and screening
so um in traffic 54.4 percent of cancers
were detected at an early stage
um and this was for the year 2017.
if you look at our statistical neighbors
trafford has the best screening rates
for us uh cervical screening for the
ages 25 to 49 which is said we covered
74.7
and for women 50 to 64 years of age 78.7
percent and this data is for 2019
and we compare it to england as a
benchmark we can say
traffic is performing better for across
both age groups
but when we look and we also look at
premature mortality for preventable
cancers in traffic
it has been declining over the last
decade
and is 78.7 per hundred thousand
population
in 2018 which is again similar to
england
or 76.3 per hundred thousand can we go
to the next slide please
so um you can see uh uh this is um
mortality from preventable cancers from
2001
uh to now you can see there's been a
steady decline
and across the years and
the mortality from preventable cancers
is uh
getting lower with each year can we go
to the next slide please
sorry this is again the wrecking of
trafford when we look up
for cervical cancer screening coverage
25 to 49
years of uh age and you can see among
its statistical labors it's one it's
amongst one of the highest ones
and here we rank fifth
and this data is for the year 2019 and
when we look at the trend our cancer
cervical screening coverage is improving
uh can we go to the next slide please
and then again this is cervical
screening for the ages 50 to 64 years of
age
and we can see the trends remain stable
but
here again trafford ranks second and uh
cancer screening uh cervical screening
coverage is
78.7 percent
and the highest in amongst our
statistical neighbors is 80.1 percent
can we have the next slide please
so um looking at the impact of mental
illness um the suicide rate in traffic
is a significantly lower
8.1 percent compared with england of
10.1 percent so um premature mortality
from serious mental illness in traffic
five times higher than the general
population of england but this data is
from
2014 to 2015 and
the percentage point gap in employment
rate from those individuals who are in
contact with secondary mental health
services
and the overall employment rate has
reduced from 71 percent
in 2015 to 2016
to 67.7 percent in 2017 to 2018.
so we can see um there's a um
can can i go to the next slide i'm sorry
this this message is coming in then it
freezes
um so this is uh when we look at the
suicide rates
um from amongst statistical labors for
trafford for the year 2017 to 2019
um traffic sorry it's got 30 trafford
ranks third
and our rates are 9.1
um um amongst neighbors and it's similar
to england as a
um as a benchmark which has 10.1
um and turrets uh first at 8.4
can we go to the um next slide i believe
this is the last slide
yes so um
we're done here
um i cannot hear anybody now thank you
very much bienish
um so i think you could i mean hopefully
that i mean it's
it's very unusual as you know for me to
be giving any good news but i think that
the smoking the changes in smoking rates
are fantastic news um
i was looking at that data and thinking
you know it
could it be possible that the work we've
been doing is actually starting to pay
off
um last year obviously we did a lot of
work with the e-cigarettes
um and i think the main thing we're now
wanting to do is make sure that we
really understand
what's caused those drops where we're
seeing those improvements
and are we managing to maintain them
particularly with covid
because i think the smoking rates and i
think quite a lot of people have stopped
smoking and covered
during cobra but i think some of the
alcohol issues have got worse and some
of the physical inactivity
we're seeing a bigger from some of the
other national data sets we're starting
to see
bigger inequalities gaps on some of
these measures so we will
finish will now be working on how do we
drill down into what's actually
happening in trafford
at that um at that neighborhood level
but with things like the cervical cancer
screening that's something that we've
been working on very hard with the ccg
with voice of bme and so on really
trying to to address our
lower rates of cervical um screening so
it does feel like some of the work that
we've been doing
is is succeeding so that is my
um optimistic message for today but i do
think we have some measures where we
still
the measures where we have the
inequalities data for example that um
childhood obesity data
that is really worrying if we can't you
know we do need to we need to be
thinking about what
what does that mean for our population
and how do we reduce those inequalities
where we have the data
it i think it is giving us a sign that i
will definitely that
the indicators that we are still
struggling with some inequalities on
some of our data sets and that means
where we don't have the data we are
likely still to see inequalities
um and i think the second um so it's
really making sure we we address those
keep that focus on and uh get those
gains
we're picking up the mental health
issues as well we are still seeing that
very big capture while it's narrowing
that's this is still very very big gap
for our
um premature mortality for people with
serious mental illness
so um it's qualif it's it's unexpected
good news but obviously i would always
qualify it
thank you yeah thank you thank you thank
you both that was uh really helpful and
really informative
and i've got two people indicating so
i'll go over to
linda do you want to come in first and
then we've got heather as well thank you
yeah thank you can i just ask about
these smoking stats
and i take it they don't include
the electronic cigarettes and
could could you just sort of comment on
that
eleanor yeah sorry yes i'm just i'm
muting so the um
it's it's smoking at time so people ask
the question about whether people are
smoking and then there's also
um it's uh supported by co2 so
it is stopping people from smoking and
e-cigarettes are if people are
continuing to use e-cigarettes
they won't be included in the data
because it doesn't cause the same damage
right yeah i i see that i still have
issues with electronic cigarettes
because
what's in them shops are popping up all
over the place selling
them are they are they properly
controlled and
what what goes into them do we know
well we've with the e-cigarette pilot
that we did of trying to move people
from
cigarettes onto e-cigarettes and ideally
then on to quitting fully
we used a we chose a supplier where we
were absolutely convinced that
everything did meet the
the required standards um so i think
there are i think the ones that
i don't know enough about what's in the
e-cigarettes but
certainly all the evidence is showing
that the an e-cigarette is much much
safer than smoking
um and that we don't know that the risk
is zero and some of the flavors do seem
to have more risk of lung
damage than others but um in the main
it's certainly whatever it is it's
certainly safer than smoking so we would
be
i think i would be worried if we started
seeing people starting
to use e-cigarettes who had never smoked
we would very much
see e-cigarettes as being something that
should be used as part of a quit aid
rather than um as a
an ongoing choice or certainly you know
i'd be very worried if we started seeing
children and young people
starting to use e-cigarettes because
particularly e-cigarettes that contain
nicotine
because if they become addicted to the
nicotine then if the e-cigarettes aren't
there they will start smoking
so it is where i'm from a public health
perspective it's
a lesser evil but it is very much
very much safer than smoking okay thank
you
thank you elena and heather do you want
to come in
uh yes please um i'm particularly
concerned about the
uh mental health um figures that were
given
and the um uh the rate at how
traffic is that much worse and of course
this is all going to be exacerbated
uh by covert and i think already
services are seeing more people
uh coming in um it's it's just
extremely worrying um
and what i hope would happen is that
from a public health perspective you can
feed in
uh to the development of the new mental
health
and strategy which is underway at the
moment and i've certainly not seen that
figure
mentioned to date and i think it's
extremely important
that we are able to try and put in some
um measures that ameliorate some of
these
um really um disturbing um
figures absolutely i think the mental
health aspects of cover but actually we
had serious issues around mental health
before any of this and we know that our
children and young people have some of
the worst mental health
in europe even before any of the covid
work and
it will not have got better we know it's
got worse um
within the public health team at the
moment we do have a clinical
psychologist as a member of our team
working on public health mental health
so at the moment we do have um
real expertise in our team that we're
we're contributing into the
development of the mental health
strategy and hannah in our team as i say
is working
working on this thank you elena and
maureen do you want to come in yeah
very quickly chair uh just to reiterate
really what what heather has said
and i i just had a query about that
mental health statistic the 70
and it referred to serious mental health
by that are we talking about severe and
enduring conditions
are we making a line of demarcation and
what are we then doing to target those
with severe and enduring
so it was a serious bit that i wasn't
sure about
um and then we know that there's a
challenge with that group of people
looks like that group of people are
increasing and how are we getting
messages and support to them um because
i think again as heather has said
and even though you know covid is a
a hopefully a temporary phenomenon it's
going to take us in a direction here
isn't it for the next
foreseeable period of time absolutely
yes and with
serious mental illness it is that um
that definition of the severe and
enduring and that's where we're seeing
that big gap
in employment in educational outcomes
and all sorts of outcomes so it's really
making sure that we
work as much as we can to make sure that
anyone with a mental illness is
supported to stay in the workplace what
we
what we when we chose that as a ambition
for the health and well-being board it
was about reducing the impact of serious
mental illness
we would love to be able to also reduce
the prevalence of serious mental illness
um and as you say with everything that
goes on we know that
that prevalence is likely to increase
therefore we need to be working even
harder
as employers as through the schools
throughout
any setting we can to make sure that
people with serious mental illness
are not excluded from services are not
excluded from the workforce
and that we can work ways of working
with people to keep people
in good gainful productive employment
and when you you know
then mental illness affects one in four
of us doesn't it at some point in our
lives many of us will be lucky enough
enough not to have a serious
form but even a short-term
mental illness can be very debilitating
for people and can really throw them off
track
so it is absolutely about trying to make
sure that we do everything we can to
limit the impact of that
and be very mindful that we are going to
see those numbers increase and therefore
all of us need to be understanding how
we do more to support that
thank you um i don't see anybody else
indicating so
and i'm not trying to rush us on
and if we can move on and i have been
notified of
one point of um any other business and
that was from tom but i can't
oh yes i can see you still tom and yeah
so tom do you want to just bring in your
and any other business thank you chair
um sorry i'm turning my video off to try
and keep my connection um
started on my phone it regardless of
laptop or phone it's not working very
well
um so it was uh and i do apologize i
should have covered it under the
communications and engagement strategy
update
um alongside the future trafford um
campaign
but i just wanted to make people aware
that this week and a lot of work has
gone into this but this week on the 15th
yesterday
um a uh nhs and care in trafford social
media facebook page has gone live
um and that is a again i think
evidence of the sort of partnership and
collaboration that we've been doing
across health and social care
um which we're using as a shared
platform to get really important
messages out so that will help evidently
help us with kobit
but actually it lays the foundations for
that longer term stuff that we want to
do as well
and that's accessible by a whole range
of partners it's owned not
necessarily by the council but it's
owned by everyone so everyone has the
administrative rights
and everyone's been involved in
developing some of the content and we're
kicking off i believe eleanor with a
a live q a session um uh with mark
jarvis as well joining you
um and it'll be followed by much more of
those things so
a really good way um to engage in a
conversation
share thoughts and feelings about how
kobe is affecting you but also about
other
other things as well um so just a really
big thank you to the people
from the comms perspective uh from the
ccg the council
mft um the lco uh the primary care
networks master call thrive
so all those organizations have been
part of uh
of coming together to formulate this new
um nhs
and care branding and again it's it it
is about
um nhs and care and much more it's not
just simply about
um the nhs and health services and so a
fantastic opportunity
for all to engage with that use it link
it
and to your own respective organizations
social media platforms
and it'll be a great way of getting
messages out there i'm sure we can
circulate the link to that new facebook
page and if everyone can push it
that'd be amazing thank you thank you
tom and
maureen and highlighted that on uh from
the 16th to the 23rd of november
it's um safeguarding adults week and
maureen did you want to
add anything further i don't think so
thanks chair uh i just wanted
that covid has slowed some of this we
we'd normally be well advanced in this
program um
but we are now developing a really
good range of resources for everyone for
professionals
and politicians members of the public
uh it will be out there on the the
safeguarding website
we'll circulate those links for everyone
and
everyone who should be involved in that
planning is currently involved
so look out for it it's going to be a
really interesting week
we can't do live events as we've done in
the past obviously
but there will be a real strong focus on
ensuring that people are linked in
to all the resources available to them
thank you maureen and tom's just
indicated that actually
if you can get some of that information
onto the new social media platform
that'd be brilliant
okay and that brings us to the end of
the agenda
so i'd like to just thank everybody for
their um
input and you know the reports from
offices you know you
you're all working really hard and i'm
sure that you're all completely
exhausted
and but try and have a rest this weekend
and see you all soon i'll
see you in about half an hour elena but
thank you everybody thank you bye-bye
thank you